today on the matt walsh show there's
finally a real and concerted effort to
push back against critical race theory
in schools but the effort should go
beyond merely pushing back i'll explain
why also five headlines including a new
report claiming that america will never
achieve herd immunity and the
coronavirus will be with us forever so
that's the good news also a viral video
shows a mother trying to plant the idea
into her daughter's head that she's
really a boy and a male democrat
congressman tells a republican woman to
quote shut her mouth and is of course
applauded by the left and finally on our
daily cancellation we'll deal once and
for all with the question
are space aliens preparing to invade and
another question even more important
why doesn't anyone seem to care
all of that and more today on the matt
walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
now word from charity mobile you know we
all complain about all these companies
out there that are uh that are
you know hopelessly low woke and far
left and everything
um but we shouldn't complain about that
if we're not willing to support the
companies that are not that the
companies that have morals and are
working with us and for us in the
culture uh here's one of those companies
charity mobile charity mobile is the
pro-life phone company and the reason
for that is five percent of your monthly
plan price goes to the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice
uh and this is all about helping to
build a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life phone company at
the same time you could turn everyday
living into effortless giving uh with
the charity of your choice but at the
same time you're also getting a great
service so five percent of your monthly
plan price goes to the uh pro-life
charity of your choice we also get new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping there's no contracts
there's no termination fees and there's
no risk with a 30-day guarantee you also
get free usage alerts you get free apps
to monitor your usage pay your bill and
so on makes it really convenient i know
i use those apps as well i've been a
charity mobile customer for a while now
and i can't say enough good things about
it so you can call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
well you know as a devoted cynic myself
i'm tempted to look at the downside in
this rather sudden push by conservatives
to fight back against and even ban
critical race theory the downside is
that we waited this long to start
fighting you know critical race theory
has been mainstream in our culture for
years kids in grade school and college
have been indoctrinated into it
for a very long time how do you think
that so many millennials ended up like
this
we didn't fall out of the sky one day
already in this
pitiful condition it took conditioning
for us to get like this years of it
and i say us only in the in the uh
broadest sense of the term
and when it comes especially to the
racial conditioning
um it took the right quite a while to
notice though
but let's not let's not focus on that
today the fact is that the racial
brainwashing
has finally come to the attention of
many people especially conservatives
and that is a good if late
perhaps even too late development
this all means that the forces which are
imposing this madness on society must
ramp up the propaganda
nbc news has gotten the memo uh leading
to this headline that they tweeted out
yesterday
in response to a school board election
in texas where crt cult members were
given a thorough drubbing but nbc news
this is how they reported it they said
opponents of anti-racism education win
big in a bitterly divided election in
south lake texas conservative candidates
who opposed a school diversity plan won
every local race
taking about 70 of the vote in the
wealthy dallas-fort worth suburb
now there's just two sentences there but
those two sentences are a
master class in dishonest framing
what you just heard there that's that's
that's what fake news is
that's what it sounds like what it looks
like
nearly every word is calculated to
mislead
starting with
opponents of anti-racism education
to even call it anti-racism education is
to choose
sides in the dispute
when you call it anti-racism education
you're declaring that you're on the side
of the crt people
the whole point that critics of crt
make is that it's not anti-racist at all
that's the entire that's really the
whole argument here or or
a major facet of the argument
is whether or not this actually is
anti-racist
by calling it anti-racist you're taking
a side
um but that's what we're saying you know
we're saying it's it's it's crt is no
more anti-racist than like a newport ad
is anti-smoking
it teaches racism
it divides people based on race it
teaches that white people are inherently
racist inherently bigoted inherently
oppressive
it treats whiteness like it's a disease
a cancer a thing that has to be
eradicated
our argument
is that
this is racist
and we're obviously correct
by calling this anti-racism education
you are again advocating for one side
you're adopting their premise and you're
pushing it under the guise of objective
reporting
and then there's the phrase bitterly
divided
nbc calls the election bitterly divided
even though conservative anti-crt
candidates won by 70 percent
now call that what you want i prefer
terms like landslide or perhaps even
butt whooping
but you can't call it bitterly divided
the vote was in fact as close to
unanimous as a vote of this kind can
hope to get
meanwhile
speaking of propaganda the founder of
the 1619 project nicole hannah jones was
on cnn yesterday responding to a letter
from mitch mcconnell where he urged
the department of education to purge
critical race theory from its curriculum
again
uh talking about
how long it took to get to this point
uh perhaps you know perhaps too late
critical race theory has been in the
curriculum for a very long time
mitch mcconnell is just now sending this
letter okay fine but here's how uh
nicole hannah jones made her case here's
what you said
as you were aware the minority leader
also wrote in his letter to the
secretary of education quote
families did not ask for this divisive
nonsense voters did not vote for it
americans never decided our children
should be taught that our country is
inherently evil
i know you uh take issues certainly with
that characterization what is your
reaction to this letter
absolutely thank you for having me on
and talking about this i i'd like to
kind of reframe the question just a bit
because this is fundamentally a free
speech issue if you look at the rhetoric
of
senator mcconnell and of state
legislators all across the country that
are trying to get bills passed to
prohibit the teaching of the 1619
project it's not about the facts of
history it's about trying to prohibit
the teaching of ideas that they don't
like so we you know i've been a little
appalled by the silence of free speech
advocates as their these attempts to ban
ideas from being taught in schools um
are being introduced all across the
country
yes free speech
that's it right we we want to ban ideas
from being tall we don't want any ideas
at all
because if you don't want the crt
critical race theory idea that means you
must be anti-ideas you don't like any
ideas if you don't like that idea then
you must not like any
right free speech teachers in schools
should have the free speech to
indoctrinate your children in whatever
way they see fit
now interestingly enough
something tells me that you'll never
hear nicole hannah jones or any of her
ilk advocating for the quote free speech
of christian public school teachers to
teach their students that i don't know
jesus christ is their lord and savior
in fact you probably won't even hear
them advocate for the free speech rights
of christian teachers to even so much as
acknowledge or mention their religious
affiliation to their kids the free
speech argument here is obviously smoke
smoke screen
all you get from crt cultists are smoke
screens and misdirections
because they can't argue their case
there's a reason why they want to inject
these ideas
into environments where they won't be
seriously questioned or criticized
most kids in school faced with
indoctrination by their teachers and
pressure from their peers they're not
going to have the capacity to resist
or to think critically about it critical
thinking is a skill that has to be
taught
it's it's it's you can't leave a kid
alone to develop it on their own because
they won't
and if you're relying on schools to
teach critical critical thinking to your
kids then they're simply never going to
learn
there's another point to be made here
also um
the backlash against critical race
theory is good
of course
we have to ask how did the schools ever
become forums for this kind of thing in
the first place
that's the real basic question
because this is
extreme extreme far left wacko stuff
how did it get into the schools
how did it get into schools
everywhere
well because the school system is a
fundamentally left-wing institution
right down to its bones
unlike a cellular level it is left-wing
and that's important to understand
because even if you eradicate crt from
the curricula and the textbooks and
everywhere else
something else will take its place
it's good to eradicate it
we should
not just in schools but everywhere
but the strategy can't be one of
perpetual defense
you know always putting out fires always
pushing back against this this leftist
indoctrination attempt and then that one
then the next one and then on and on and
on
as conservatives and especially as
parents
our ultimate goal should be not just to
free our kids of left-wing
indoctrination
but to actively raise them
and educate them
according to our own values and our own
worldview
this is a point that
i'm emphasizing all the time and cannot
be emphasized enough
um the problem with for example critical
race theory
is not simply that it is indoctrination
it's that it is wrong
it's bad
it's evil
it's harmful it's dangerous it's toxic
that's the problem with it
but indoctrination
that is you know when we're talking
about kids anyway bringing that up them
up in a certain world view
um introducing them
and inculcating a value system into a
child i mean that's that is induction
that is a form of indoctrination
anytime you when you hopefully at home
are teaching values to your children
you're indoctrinating them
and that's good
that's something that you should be
doing as a parent that's something that
kids need
the question is whether it is good
indoctrination or bad
and when it comes to education
there is always going to be you are
never going to have an education that is
totally free of worldview totally free
of of a value system totally free of
indoctrination unless it's robots doing
the educating
you're always going to have that
and so the next phase the next part of
this
is to go is to get away from this
defensive stance
and to focus as parents in on actively
bringing our kids up and educating them
in to the proper and right and good
value system
to a properly ordered world view
that has to be the goal
we can't just
get rid of critical race theory and then
sit back and say well we've our job here
is done
they'll just replace it with something
else on and on and on forever
until we begin actively raising our kids
with the correct value system that will
help them become
well-adjusted good people that has to be
the goal
and now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you have now only well less than a week
until mother's day and if you haven't
thought if you haven't even thought
about
what kind of mother's day gift you're
gonna get then do you even love your
mother you selfish
person you well let me help you out um
the pearl source they're one of our
newest sponsors on the show with the
pearl source you can get the highest
quality pearl jewelry at up to 70 off
retail prices pearl source cuts out the
middle man by eliminating traditional uh
markups by jewelry stores and selling
directly to you the consumer they have
the largest selection of pearls
available anywhere and each jewelry
piece is custom made for you
the or for whoever you're but you're
buying the pearls for the pearl source
offers fast and free two-day shipping on
every order with zero contact delivery
everything comes beautifully packaged in
an elegant jewelry box so it's ready to
be given as a gift
so this is this is you know i'm bailing
you out right the pearl source is
bailing you out if you're looking for a
mother's day gift um this is the way to
go and just because it's a gift doesn't
mean you can't save money on it you know
that's the best best of both worlds
don't over pay for jewelry go to the
pearl source and save up to 70 off of
retail prices and for a limited time
listeners to my show you get 20 off
their entire order for mother's day go
to thepearlsource.com and to promo code
wall should check out for 20 off your
entire order if you want fine pearl
julia the best prices online then go
straight to the source the pearlsource
pearlsource.com enter promo code walsh
at checkout
you know i'm at a phase right now
um
difficult phase myself where i'm my my
body is middle aged i guess i'm almost
35 i think that counts as middle age
but my emotional and mental maturity
hasn't quite caught up to that
so i did something to my back over the
weekend um it might have been when i was
at the gym lifting on saturday or it
might have been when i bent down to pick
up a jar of peanut butter that had
fallen out of the pantry and i could
have done i don't know what it was but i
have been in extreme discomfort
um and then yesterday while we took the
kids to a playground
and i was playing on the jungle gym
and uh now my back feels ten times worse
and the question is you know what kind
of grown adult plays on the jungle gym
to begin with
and what kind of [ __ ] does it when he's
already injured his back
well me i mean this this [ __ ] is is who
does that and this is also why now i
can't go to the doctor for it because my
wife is saying well you got to go to the
doctor i'm not big on doctors in general
because i'm a stereotypical man
but i can't go and explain this whole
story about you know i did something on
my back and i was playing on a jungle
gym and i injured it more i could say it
to you because i i don't see you i'm
just talking to a camera
i can't
sit in front of a doctor and say that
so i will just suffer in silence well
not really in silence i'm complaining i
will suffer loudly is what i will do
as any man should okay this is from the
new york times it says early in the
pandemic when vaccines for the
chronovirus were still just a glimmer on
the horizon
the term herd immunity came to signify
the endgame
the point where enough americans will be
protected from the virus so we could get
rid of the pathogen and reclaim our
lives now more than half of adults in
the united states have been um
inoculated with at least one dose of a
vaccine but daily vaccination rates are
slipping and there's widespread
consensus among scientists and public
health experts that the herd immunity
threshold is not attainable
at least not the foreseeable future and
perhaps not ever
instead they're coming to the conclusion
that rather than making a long promised
exit
the virus will most likely become a
manageable threat that will continue to
circulate in the u.s for years to come
still causing hospitalizations and
deaths but in smaller numbers uh so
that's the
this is going viral right now on social
media
that's the claim from
the new york times anyway
that there's never going to be hurt
immunity
and not just the new york times dr liana
wen was formerly of planned parenthood
and she was on cnn
echoing these concerns that we will
never have hurt immunity here's what she
said
we're going to get to herd immunity
through a balance of those who've had it
and those who got vaccinated so this
conversation is all about how that will
be balanced and if we can get there
through more vaccination fewer people
will get sick and die how's that
well i certainly agree with you on
everything you said in your intro
i also
though i'm not sure that we are going to
reach her immunity i mean the other
scenario here is that we get a decline
in the number of infections because of
increasing vaccinations over the summer
that's really good but i also fear that
people are going to get complacent
they're going to see that things are
returning to normal they can go about
doing things that they can
that they were able to before regardless
of whether they were vaccinated and what
i really worry about is that those
people who are already on the fence
don't get vaccinated we don't reach herd
immunity come the fall and then with the
winter because coronaviruses are winter
respiratory viruses we have a big
resurgence maybe we have variants coming
in from other countries and we could
start this whole process all over again
and have another huge pandemic come the
winter and so that's why getting to herd
immunity now as much as possible is
really important
so they're they're they're never going
to let this go is what they're basically
saying if i were to can translate here
um
at best there will be laws
in the
panic porn that we get from the media
and the quote
public health experts and then we get
around the fall in wintertime they're
going to ramp it up again
maybe at best we'll end up with these
kind of
um mask mandates and everything that
that
are are imposed and then taken away and
then opposed again depending on the
season i don't know
but they're never gonna fully let it go
and as far as whether we reach herd
immunity i don't have much of an opinion
on that i think probably a lot of it
depends on what you mean by herd
immunity
um
but
i also it doesn't surprise me you know i
me as as someone i'm not an expert and
i'll fully admit that from day one i uh
unlike some of these other experts on
these supposed experts on cable news who
claim to be but aren't
um i will tell you i'm not an expert but
from my non-expert point of view
early on
it seemed
pretty likely to me anyway that we'd
always that the coronavirus the kova 19
would always be with us in some form
it's always going to be out there it's
probably not going to just go away
completely
and so if that's what they mean then
sure
that doesn't surprise me
it's always going to be out there in
some form
perhaps
uh
so the question really is
the question now is the same question
that we've been faced with from the
beginning which is
it's here
maybe it's always going to be here in
some form
and to some degree
are you going to live your life or not
you can choose to live your life in
spite of that reality
um
or you can huddle under your bed in fear
trembling
those those are really the two choices
that's the choice that we that you you
know we were faced with back in march of
2020 it's the same choice now
i know for me i'm i'm gonna live my life
there are many many risks out there
many many things that could kill me at
any time
uh and one of those things will kill me
eventually
and i'm i'm
fully aware of that
covert 19 has always been
just for me one of those things in that
category
although in terms of things likely to
kill me it's it for me personally as a
low-risk person for cover it's way down
a list
but it's there along with all these
other things and i'm aware of that and
i'm going to live my life until i'm not
living it anymore
that's what we all have to decide
number two representative marjorie
taylor green tweeted this over the
weekend uh is what she said
democrat policies are destructive and
america last
dem shutdowns killed hundreds of
thousands of small businesses
dem open borders uh grow cartel business
to 400 million dollars per month and
democrat funded blm slash antifa riots
have cost billions of damage
democrats are the enemy within
so that's what she tweeted
and that's all that is true of course
completely true
but the democrats didn't like it so
congressman rubin gallagher who is a
congressman from arizona he responded
with this
i was trying to figure out what type of
pen to stab your friends with if they
overran us on the floor of the house of
representatives while trying to conduct
a democratic transition of power
so please shut your seditious q a
non-loving mouth when it comes to who
loves america
like now we're gonna leave aside the
melodrama about i was looking for a pen
to step
this is a line that we've heard not just
from this guy but a lot of democrats
have
i guess they found that to be a powerful
image i don't think it particularly is
but um
they're searching for pens to stab
someone with because they thought they
were about to die any moment
uh we're gonna leave that melodramatic
bs aside for a moment
but here he is talking to a woman and an
elected representative of this country
saying
shut your mouth
shut your seditious q anon loving mouth
and
this response from him went viral
obviously and obviously the left was
celebrating it they loved it uh they you
go girl and everything they thought it
was fantastic
um
but we know
doesn't need to need to be said but i
will say it
if a republican had responded to for
example maxine waters when she
uh left d.c and went out to minnesota to
rile the mob up
in the lead-up to the chauvin verdict
if if a republican had said to maxine
waters hey shut your mouth
shut your race baiting lying riot
inciting mouth
you can only imagine
the response from the left
the screams of sexism and misogyny would
be deafening
you know what i'm
i'm really tired of pointing out these
double standards
and whining about them and complaining
no
instead of
whining about the double standard
we should reject it
okay so
when the left
sets uh
new rules for itself
then we say okay well then we could play
by those rules too
if those are the rules according to you
then i have every right to play by them
also
and that's what republicans should start
doing i know they won't
but a republican should come out to
maxine water say hey shut your mouth
aoc next time she's droning on
shut your mouth aoc
that's what they should do
and of course the left will react how
they're going to react who cares how
they react
and whatever republican had the the
stones to say that can say hey look you
guys you've already you've already made
it clear these are the rules now and i'm
going to play by them i don't care no no
so you say that only you're allowed to
play by them i i reject that
i'm not going to complain about the
double standard i reject it
you have set that standard and if i want
to
take advantage of it i will
i don't care what you say
so this is the rule now
men in congress are allowed to tell
women in congress to shut their mouths
you know what that's fair anyway
we live in a in a feminist
society all about equality and equity
and all these things well
men talk this way to each other
okay
that's what needs that but but
republicans won't see what they do is
they abide
by the double standard while whining
about it
the left says here's the rules for us
here are the rules for you over here
and then republicans
obey those rules while complaining oh
gee this this is really this isn't fair
why do i have to play by these rules
no offense shake their fists
impotently
that's your choice to play by them
i mean i'll say it maxine waters you
should shut your mouth you really should
in a lot of ways
all right speaking of maxine waters who
needs to shut her mouth
maxine waters did an interview over the
weekend responding to tim scott's claim
that america is not racist
and uh she she didn't like that she
really did she's very upset
here's what she said
well you know
i don't know if he was counseled
uh to say that or whether he really
believes that if he really believes that
then he has missed not only the history
of the country but what is going on
right now as we watched uh the invasion
of the capital on january 6 and
those people following trump saying they
were taking back uh their government and
they were willing to harm people uh as a
matter of fact uh not only were they
willing to harm people uh for the
capitol police who happened to be people
you know police of color
african-american they were calling them
names uh the n-word um
every day we have seen you know this
nation
get more racist
than anybody thought perhaps would be at
this point in time we've been through
the civil rights movement where of
course we made some progress but this uh
president that we had trump was taking
us backwards
and he was making racist comments uh he
was uh you know identifying himself with
people like the ku klux klan and the
proud boys and the oath keepers and the
uh q anon i mean that is racism defined
uh in the most uh obvious way and so to
say that this is not a racist country
maybe he meant to say that there are
many people who are not racist in this
country but yes we have a problem with
racism and that we must work to do
something about it maybe that's what he
meant to say
okay shut your mouth maxine definitely
shut your mouth um no that's not what he
meant to say maybe no you know maybe he
meant
there's no way he disagreed with me it's
not possible uh no one can disagree with
me i i think what he meant to to say was
that he agrees with me
that must be what he meant to say this
is not possible how could anyone
disagree with me
yeah
um i i will agree with this
if donald trump
had what was the phrase she used
identified himself with the ku klux klan
if he had done that if he had identified
himself with the kkk
then i would agree that's totally racist
but he didn't
ever
at all
nothing close to that
nothing that could be construed that way
he i
this just this is what she does
that's why she's the most corrupt
dishonest
reprehensible member of congress
and is up there like for the all for one
of the all-time positions in that
category by the way
just makes makes stuff up
donald trump identified himself with the
kkk okay and it isn't challenged
obviously by
uh by the supposed news anchor there
okay well you know what
if america america keeps getting ready
america gets more and more racist every
day
she says
all right you know what fine america
gets more and more racist every day than
uh if if that's what you think
then i guess we could stop with all
these anti-racist measures
maybe this is the argument against crt
it's obviously not working
so we've had years and years of
anti-racism
uh critical race theory
you know diversity education everything
years and years of this and maxi water
says we're only getting more racist
it's not even like where racism is is
going away slower than we thought
it's getting more racist
that's her she thinks that
so
that means that this stuff isn't working
i mean if anything it's making the
situation worse
the thing is i actually you know this is
this is the part i actually agree with i
agree with her about that
america is getting more racist
just not in the way that she thinks or
will say
because in fact um critical race theory
and this obsession with race dividing
people based on race all of that stuff
it it it is it is making the country
more racist
it's just that a whole lot of that
racism is
targeted
against white people
and that's what happens when you have a
whole group of people and you make them
the scapegoats and the villains
and you treat their identity like a
sickness
you know whiteness has become synonymous
with uh with with evil and all the bad
things in the world
yeah when you do that you're going to
increase racism against that group
that's not a surprise that's the reason
you're doing it
so even though we agree for very
different reasons
it sounds like in both cases this is an
argument for getting rid of all these
anti-racism measures um
they are either not working at all
or they are creating the racism
but what you can't claim is that they
are
that that they are successfully
combating racism
if america is only more and more racist
each day as maxine waters
says
all right i want to leave some time uh
for this
i want to play this video you know we
play tick-tock videos on the show uh
frequently and
oftentimes they're
they're always deranged and disturbing
but but sometimes in a somewhat funny
way
this is a not a funny one of course this
is not one we can laugh about
it is ludicrous in the extreme but it's
not at all funny
um here is a mother who took this video
put it proudly on tick tock
uh showing
how she is
like a munchausen by proxy situation how
she is trying to impose gender dysphoria
on her
innocent little daughter let's watch
are you a boy are you a girl
i don't know
i don't know who
[Music]
[Music]
what makes you think that
mommy can i get this
okay so a little hard to hear there if
you're listening on the audio podcast
especially with the
with the music which just makes us so
much
sicker uh
that music in the background but
the video is of a girl six years old
and
the mother is like interrogating her
and she's got the camera out she's
recording it
oh and there's there's words on the
screen says my six-year-old daughter
asks me if i think she looks like a boy
and i asked her do you want to look like
a boy her response left me speechless
speechless
as if she had some profound response to
that she didn't
in fact what she said originally was
this what
actually there was there was one
profound thing that that the child said
uh she said earlier in the video
i don't know who i am
and the mother is
pushing her along guiding her along
towards gender confusion
and then she says something like i i
think i'm a boy i feel like a boy
but what she said there i don't know who
i am
that is about as true a statement as a
six-year-old child can ever make
and it's a profound truth
a child at that age doesn't know who
they are
and she is at some level aware that she
doesn't know who she is which is very
interesting
um
and maybe that awareness comes from
having a parent who's obsessed with
identity and always trying to impose
these things and so this this this child
appears to like feel
all kids are confused about their
identity and who they are all kids are
um
this is something they come to
understand gradually with age
but she is aware of her own confusion
more
mostly because she has an abusive mother
psychologically abusive mother um
but i don't know who i am
and then and then she settles oh i think
i'm a boy
but all you have to do is watch that
video
and you can see
that really what you're dealing with
here there's no mystery
there's nothing at all it this is a
child who is basically
babbling nonsensically
touches on a few truths here and there i
don't know who i am
but for the most part as kids do at that
age and for years thereafter
kind of babbling
saying words doesn't really know exactly
what she's saying
and what do these parents do they
seize on that
confusion
and they exploit it
and then they and then they they take
these children they put them on display
for the whole world to see
that mother by the way i did look up her
uh tick tock
account and
she uh was responding to some of the
critics and of course she was making a
victim of herself so i wasn't expecting
i was expecting all this this big
response and and
trying to defend and and make a victim
of herself
but she she's so surprised
that this video got a lot of attention
and she was being criticized for it and
rightly so
yeah well
if you didn't want attention
then why did you put it online
this is the other thing these parents
always do
which sends me through the roof
is
they put their child on display for the
whole world
they publicize this stuff even though
nobody asked them to
and then when when people share their
opinions
the parents will retreat back to this is
our private life it's none of your
business stay out of our lives
if it's not our business why are you
telling us about it
see when you put something out there
into into the public domain for everyone
to see
you're going to get people's opinions
we're allowed to have opinions opinions
about anything
any information you give me
i am going to have an opinion about it
because i have a brain
and i'm allowed to
if you don't want my opinion about it
don't tell me about it
no they want our opinion
it's just that they want our opinion to
validate
the psychological trauma and abuse that
they are
imposing on their child that's what they
want
and when they don't get that then they
uh then then they become the victims
because as i always point out
this is all about the parent
it's got nothing to do with the kid
the the children are
spectators you know
in a weird way the children become
spectators of their own identity crisis
as the parents create this identity
crisis on their own
and the kids are just sitting back
looking at it like what is what's mom
doing what is what's happening right now
absolutely disgusting
yet another parent who should be in jail
um
all right let's move to reading the
youtube comments
this one says matt have your wife lay
out your clothes the night before and
you won't have to remember which shirt
to wear on fridays
well she actually does lay out my
clothes uh most
like i told you i have the emotional
mental maturity of a child so
she does lay my clothes most days but um
she is not
i yeah this is really her fault i guess
that i i miss polka dot friday i guess
we could blame her i'm not going to take
any accountability
but she is not a proponent
i hate to be airing
my own dirty laundry so to speak
but my wife is not a proponent of a
polka dot friday she's not on board with
it really
she's very anti-polka dot friday
and uh
yeah she laid out a shirt and i just put
it on
because i'm gonna wear whatever shirt is
put before me to wear
not my fault
thank you yeah you know what this i was
wondering who to blame and i've realized
it's my wife she used to blame for this
um okay
another one says congratulations on the
250 000 subs matt even though youtube
hates you and us it's still a fine
achievement and well deserved
good sir
well
yeah we did reach we crossed 250 000
subscribers so
yeah we started at at the beginning of
uh like mid 2020 we had i don't know how
many we had
a pitifully low number so we're uh we're
climbing
christian says please react to rap star
by polo g in your next rap review it's
currently the number one song in the
country for two weeks now and i would
love to see your take on this modern
masterpiece of western civilization i'm
sensing a little bit sarcasm there i
haven't heard of
of this artist known as polo g he sounds
great by the name
i have been looking for another uh raps
rap masterpiece to review for youtube
and and maybe i'll i'll check that one
out
um
devon says i really enjoyed your book
church of cowards when will your next
book come out
well i i am actually working all i can
say is i'm working on a book project
right now
and it's not what you expect
it's
it's going in a completely different
direction from what you probably expect
and that's all i can say right now
and finally i had a bunch of comments
about the pitbull topic which we touched
on briefly during the five headlines
yesterday uh one comment says i disagree
with your pitbull statement and the idea
that since they're capable of mauling
someone as a reason to ban them as
that's what the left says about police
they have the possibility to mull
someone and why take the risk another
one says matt's argument against pit
bulls is the same argument the left uses
against second amendment another one
says matt i think you should talk to
caesar the dog whisperer he he will tell
you that it's the owners who have a
problem not the dogs
and beau says when you say pitbull
should be banned you sound like a
leftist mat don't be a leftist you're
better than that yeah these are the kind
of arguments i always hear with the pit
bull thing it's uh it's like the second
amendment is no no or or oh you're a
leftist wanting to ban things
first of all i i am not of the opinion
that only the left wants to ban things i
am totally in favor of banning some
things it depends on what the thing is
this is the kind of
overly simplistic conservatism that we
have to move past we have to grow beyond
it where we
we
we pretend that if you're banning the
left they're the only ones who want to
ban stuff of course i want to ban things
there are plenty of things that are
currently banned that i think should be
banned
uh i don't know we can start with murder
is banned you know that should be banned
um and i'm in critical race theory
should be banned from our schools we
just talk about that i think most
conservatives agree so
there's nothing wrong with banning
things
the question is is it a thing that
should be banned
now guns aren't banned because we we
have that is a right expressly
guaranteed to us in the bill of rights
and also it's it's necessary
in order to preserve our liberty we need
to have
um
we need to have the ability to defend
ourselves
uh so
and then the the comparison to the
police is
downright silly again we need law
enforcement officers if because if we
need to have a law we need to have law
in order to live in a in a civilized
society and we're starting to see what
it looks like to live in a society that
is not civilized so if you want to have
a civilized society you need law and
then you need law enforcers
okay
so you've got with guns it's a
guaranteed constitutional right and also
it's necessary law enforcement again
necessary
um pit bulls are not any of those things
they're not necessary
they're not a constitutional guaranteed
right but even that's not that's not
even the point the point is that they're
not a necessary thing
um it's uh it's a
you know a privilege that you have to
own a dog like this or bring a dog like
this into the community
um
and it's a question of whether it's
worth the risk
you know whatever your desire is you
know whatever your reason for getting a
pit bull
um people have reasons for not wanting
pit bulls in their community
and whose claim should outweigh
the other in this case
and it seems to me that your reason for
wanting a pit bull is that they're cute
to you and uh you kind of and that's it
i mean that's really your reason right
you think they're cute
and you think it's fun to have one
okay
fine
um the reason people might not want pit
bulls in their community is that every
year
uh children and other people are mulled
to death by them and they are inherently
dangerous animals um and they
you know they are they are
in their nature aggressive
and capable of killing people and that's
why you might not want them in your
community so i i tend to think
that people don't want them in the
community i i think their
claim outweighs
your desire to have a cute animal
that's it
by the way same reason we don't allow in
most places you can't have wild animals
you can't have like a chimpanzee or
something
in your house uh these are dangerous
animals yeah they're cute they're
dangerous you can't have them i would
put the same thing with the with pit
bulls as i'm sure you all know the daily
wire has been growing like crazy not
only did we move the whole company
across the country we also released our
first feature film we struck up a movie
deal with gina carano we've launched uh
the new show by candace owens all within
the last six months only imagine what
else we have to do
uh we're moving at the speed of light
over here and that's why i'm excited for
the future of the company and um all of
us here at the daily wire would like to
express our gratitude to you for keeping
us afloat we want to
make sure we include you in all of our
future plans every day on my show
i talk about a lot of amazing products
as i just did a second ago services also
from sponsors that i love and use myself
we want to get to know you better so we
can choose sponsors
with you in mind so please go to
dailywire.com walsh and fill out my
audience survey to tell us a little bit
about yourself and to sweeten the whole
experience those of you that complete
the survey will be entered to win a 1
000 gift card but you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show so if
you want to increase your chance of
winning a thousand dollars then go
listen to ben shapiro michael knowles
andrew clavin and get access to their
surveys as well and again my survey link
is dailywire.com
walsh now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so today we have a daily cancellation
that has a been a long time coming some
of you out there have been begging to
get cancelled for this and now the
moment has arrived
the catalyst is a piece in the new
yorker published a few days ago written
by gideon lewis krause titled how the
pentagon started taking ufos seriously
the article goes into great length
discussing the evolution of the ufo
issue or uap unidentified aerial
phenomenon as they're now called though
i personally choose to stick with the
traditional name as an old-fashioned guy
now i'm not canceling the new yorker for
this article far from it it's quite
fascinating and it makes the case that
um
that has been made on this show at other
times
what we know
is that for decades up until the past
few years ufos were an area of thought
and study reserved for wackos and
crackpots or at least those perceived to
be wackos and crackpots
but then things began to shift the
pentagon started admitting
that it was aware of and had been
investigating many reports of strange
aircraft in our skies doing things
these aircraft were doing things that
don't seem possible by our current
technology and understanding what's more
many sightings have been made by
military personnel often the objects are
spotted over nuclear facilities and
military installations these are trained
technicians making these observations
not random yokels in a field somewhere
these are people whose job is to spot
threats in our skies and who presumably
know what a weather balloon looks like
or a drone looks like
and they're saying that these things
these crafts
are not that
they're something else and they look
different too there are reports of a
tick tick tic-tac-shaped objects and
discs
and flying pyramid-looking things
and then the government began releasing
videos of what some navy pilots had seen
up in the sky sure enough it appeared to
be vehicles of some kind going way
faster than current technology allows
also not making any sound while they're
doing it stopping on a dime shooting off
in another direction sometimes dipping
into the ocean and coming back out and
making all kinds of other maneuvers that
just don't seem possible
these are
the sightings that we know about also
other government officials and former
government officials have come out and
said that there are many many more that
we don't know about
now the department of defense is
expected to release a report to congress
early this summer
revealing what it knows about ufos
the point
is that this is all quite unprecedented
ufo sightings are not unprecedented
we've heard about them as i said for
decades plenty of those sightings have
proven to be hoaxes or misunderstandings
some of them are still unexplained
but now we have the government
confirming
and providing video evidence of
unidentified flying objects
they're admitting that they've
investigated these things and
they remain totally stumped
some former government officials have
even openly speculated that the objects
might be otherworldly in origin
now this kind of openness and
transparency on this issue from the
government after decades of stonewalling
or pretending to laugh it off
is pretty shocking
so all in all no matter what your theory
is no matter what you think is going on
this is a major story and it's
fascinating
and something that should be attracting
way more attention and interest than it
is
so that's why i'm canceling most of the
american public today for failing to
give this the attention and interest
that it deserves
i mean the government is out here
confirming the existence of ufos
providing videos of them
and preparing an official report to
congress on the subject and a lot of you
are responding
with a sigh and a yawn
you're first
yeah
it's unconscionable to me
now i'm not saying
that you have to believe that aliens are
visiting the earth what i'm saying is
that
something is going on and whatever it is
it's a big deal
so it seems to me that there are there
are four plausible explanations for this
for everything that's happening
um the weather balloon slash lens flare
slash camera trick slash hallucination
explanations are not on the list are not
really plausible anymore because we have
now video and testimony from expert
trained observers and pilots
so it's very clear that whatever these
things are they are actual things not
figments of anyone's imagination
and they're not standard technology
so that leaves four explanations
one
a foreign a foreign earthly adversary
has developed a technology so
incomprehensibly advanced and beyond our
own capabilities that our government has
no idea what it is or how it works
two
our own government has developed
technology so incomprehensibly advanced
and so top secret that the people
investigating ufos of the pentagon don't
know about it and aren't being told
three that this is all some elaborate
psy-op by our government some big
distraction technique
for
that there are intelligent beings in the
universe
elsewhere than earth
and we are currently under their
surveillance okay now
i don't know which of these explanations
are correct i tend to doubt number three
that the government is making all this
up to distract us
mostly i i doubt it because it's not
working it's it's not distracting us so
if this is a distraction technique it's
a pretty bad one
very few people seem to care also if
they wanted to distract us with stories
of ufos why do they spend like 70 years
denying all these stories
but whatever the explanation
whether this is technology from china or
it's our own technology or technology
from some other place unknown to us
the point is that it's a big deal
something significant is happening
what's more it's interesting
it's way more interesting than almost
everything else we spend our time
droning on about
my issue here is not that the american
public disagrees with me about the
origin of these objects i don't know the
origin so you can't disagree with me
about that i have no idea
my issue is that much of the public and
the media
seems not to care very much one way or
another
and that's the thing i i can't
understand
there are actual flying saucers or
flying tic tacs
zipping around the skies defying the
laws of physics
nobody seems to know what they are where
they came from and most people are
looking up and going ah big deal
let's see what's on netflix
that's the thing that frustrates me in
fact the public cares much more about
movies about ufos than it does about the
real thing
i am convinced that if space aliens
actually landed on earth and were about
to emerge from their ships
and divulge the secrets of the universe
and a new star wars movie was premiering
at the same time in the ultimate case of
counter programming
most americans would rather go watch the
movie about the aliens than go see the
real thing
we are a nation of zombies with moldy
brains incapable of awe and wonder
that's what this is really about
it's all in wonder
you see video like that and you hear
stories like this like wow that's that's
this is amazing
something crazy is happening
let's talk about that
what makes this ufo issue so captivating
is that we don't know what's happening
it gives us a chance to wonder and think
and theorize
but a lot of people don't want to think
they want their thoughts pre-made
pre-assembled
presented to them on a platter
everything requires deeper thought is
uninteresting because we lack the
capacity for deeper thought you might
recall a couple years ago
when scientists released
the first ever image of a black hole
it was an image of an intergalactic
object some 55 million light years away
amazing
but most people shrugged it off you know
they shrugged when it was released and
they complained that the picture was too
blurry and not that exciting
that's blurry i can't see it
this is boring
yes it was blurry
i mean it's from 55 million light years
away what do you want
but what made it exciting was the very
thought that this image came to us from
55 million light years away
we're able to look back through time and
space and see something massive and
ancient and mysterious
the image itself on the surface
was just a blurry mess of colors yeah
but the image combined with the thought
of what it is
and what it means and the implications
that's what made it fascinating
yet this requires us to have actual
thoughts
just as the ufo story requires us to
have thoughts
on the surface these are just weird
things buzzing around in the sky but
think deeper
and the possibilities are truly awesome
and incredible
sadly though the think deeper part is
where we lose a lot of people
and all of those people are canceled
and by the way they're also not invited
to the welcome party when the aliens
arrive
not that those boring losers would want
to come anyway so i guess no loss
and
we will leave it there for today all of
you who
have not just been canceled uh i hope
you have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadasky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nika geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show cnn suggests that
misinformation from the right will cause
a civil war but it is the establishment
media's embrace of radical critical race
theory that will split the country
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen